our subject
holy for god
our theme
is holy
for christ
and god speak all these words
say i am the law thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
thou shalt have no other gods before me
thou shalt not make unto thee any driven
image
or any likeness of anything
that is in heaven above
or that is the earth beneath
or that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them
for i the lord thy god am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
ensuing mercy
unto thousands of them that love me
and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord
thy god in vain
for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain
remember the sabbath day to keep it
holy
six days shalt thou labor
and do all thy work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it
thou shalt not do any work
thou
not thy son
nor thy daughter
thy man's servant
nor thy midservant
nor thy cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy
gates for in six days the lord made
heaven and earth
the sea and all that in them is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
honor thy father
and thy mother
that thy days may be long upon the land
which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not commit adultery
thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
house
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant
nor his maidservant
nor his ox
nor his ass
nor anything
that is thine is
god is good
and all the time
happy sabbath everyone
thank you very much for coming to the
house of god
to listen to his word
it is my honor
it is my privilege
it is my delightful
joy
to stand before you
to speak for god
i can think of no higher privilege
other than to reflect god in life
than to speak for god
it's a very solemn responsibility
and my intention as best as my humanity
will permit me
is to give you
thus saith the lord
prophets and kings page 6 26 paragraph
one
elohim writes
the words of the bible
and the bible alone should be heard from
the pulpit
this is my intention my desire
and by the grace of god i will give you
thus saith the lord and of course
that inspired commentary
from the pen
of ellen white
the servant to this church
it is 21 minutes to 12.
i am unfamiliar with when you get out
but i'll try to release you as soon as i
possibly can
without rushing the spirit of god
is there anyone with us today you are
not a seven
that
god bless you
thank you for coming
are you together
the lord bless your lives
and guide you right into his kingdom
when he comes
please keep coming to worship with us
until that happy day
when i look at you again and i'll be
looking at two members of the seventh
day adventist church can you say amen
say it again
anybody else you are not a seventh-day
adventist
nice your hand ah
i see a hand moving in the
balcony god bless you thanks for waving
your hand i have picked you out
may the lord bless your life
may the lord grant you the desires of
your heart with such abundance
that his goodness to you
will move you
to serve him with all your heart and
soul
thank you very much
worship with us again
anyone else
you are not
okay
thank you my lovely sister
let me take a chance what's your name
[Music]
all right all right
but god knows exactly what it is
thank you very much for coming
and may lord place a hand of mercy on
your life
and never remove it
say amen for our sister
anyone else you're not a seventh
yeah
is that it
well move the hand so i can like that oh
there you are
what's your name
actually god bless your life
god bless your family
and god bless you so torrentially
that you will be a blessing to others
say amen for ashy
anyone else and i'm not joking these are
prayers i'm praying for our guests this
is no joke
anybody else
okay
did i miss someone where
oh hi
i see those two hands thank you for
coming
is this your first time you're visiting
with us
in the balcony say something
what did the person say
yes
we don't want it to be the last
if you have a need
may the lord supply it
if you have a sickness
may the lord remove it
and if you have an
enemy
thanks for coming
and god bless you in every possible way
say amen
[Music]
did you raise your hand sister
or you were saying amen
okay it's uh
19 minutes to 12
and temperance and all things including
sermons
before i go any further
let me ask you to do three favors for me
favor number one
if you have a bible
and the form
i prefer that you use this
over there
this is the holy bible
this is not the holy iphone
are you with me no i'm quite serious
this does not ring
[Music]
this has no temptation to check whatsapp
instagram
the fiber
whatever else
occupies our time
this comes loaded with temptations
i was in a hotel room a few years ago
preparing to go speak downstairs
and i was reading the bible on this
thing
and these smartphones they have
while you're reading or doing whatever
you're doing
an app or something popped up at the
bottom of an advertisement
and he said
hey
are you lonely
no that's what it said
it was an advertisement for dating asian
women
i was in the room by myself
all i needed to do was take the tip of
one finger
and touch it on all the information
would have come
to the preacher
reading the word of
god what i'm saying to you is this
[Music]
this does not
it has all the power of the universe
so if you can use one of these
do that if all you saddled with is this
then please
don't let it ring
in the presence of a holy god and under
no circumstances walk out of the church
to answer the phone unless you're the
physician to the president of the
country
and he needs your services other than
that respect the god of heaven and earth
if that's reasonable say amen
the second favor i ask very polite
to me while i'm speaking
all i want you to say is lord
put your words
in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
the lord said unto me behold i have put
my words
in thy mouth
i only want to speak
god's words
i will surely be tempted to speak
mine but my has no my words have no
saving value
but the words of god jesus said
they are spirit
and they are life
so ask god
to put his words
in my mouth
and favor number three i want you to
think
as you listen
isaiah 1 18
come now
let us reason together said the lord
think as you listen
and don't chat
don't do anything to offend the spirit
of god
and that also may disturb me
let's pray
father in heaven
thank you for allowing me to live to see
this day
hearing to listen to your people saying
i thank you for vision to see them
and to see the sunlight
and the grass i saw this morning
and the guinea fowl i saw running across
the meadow
i thank you thank god
for sanity
thank you for knowledge of jesus christ
one verse says
he hath not dealt with us after our sins
not rewarded us
according to our iniquities
dear god thank you
for not giving me the full punishment i
deserve
ah god if i've offended you forgive me
you know i'm weak
i am dirty
i am clay
i ask you now lord
through the agency of your spirit
take full possession of my mind
my mouth
my heart
so that i am simply an instrument in
your hand
and let the tune you play is the tune of
truth
father bless all those who have come
and a god
i ask you to pour out a special blessing
on the visitors
[Music]
touch
let this day
long remain in their minds
now god bless not only us
but wherever your people are worshiping
you on this holy day your bible sabbath
bless them god
bless this country
and every country represented by this
congregation
let the leaders always remember in all
the deliberations
righteousness exalted the nation
and by the way father remind us
exalteth an individual
i commit this message to your glory day
god
suppress self i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
our subject
holy for god
our theme
is holy
for christ
the message today
holy
for god
mark 12
reading from verse 28
mark chapter 12
reading from verse 28.
i read from the king james version
of the bible
if you have my version at all times feel
free to read with me
mark 12
reading from verse 28.
try to find these passages quickly
so i can move quickly
and release you
quickly
do you have it now
and one of the scribes came
and having heard them reasoning together
and perceiving that he answered them
well asked him
which is the first commandment of all
and jesus answered him the first of all
the commandment is here or israel the
lord our god is one lord
and thou shalt love the lord thy god
save me now with all thy heart and with
all thy soul and with all thy mind and
with all thy strength this
is the first commandment and we stop
right there
well let's continue and the second is
like namely this
thou shall love thy neighbor as thyself
there is none of the commandment
greater than these
and the scribe said
master
thou has said the truth
for there is one god one lord and there
is none other than he
and to love him
with all the heart
and with all the understanding and with
all the soul and with all the strength
and to love his neighbor as himself is
more than all whole burnt offerings
and sacrifices
when jesus saw that he answered
discreetly
he said unto him
thou art not far
from the kingdom of god
and no man after that
there's to ask him
any question
this crime
perhaps a lawyer
asked jesus
[Music]
of all the commandments
which is the preeminent one
you see god is a god of degrees and i
don't mean academic degrees
jesus tells us
he that love his father and mother more
than me
is not worthy of me what is the
conclusion we must love god more than we
love anyone else we must have degrees of
love
you must love god more than you love
your husband
your wife
your children
your job
your bank account
your friends
your shoes
we must love god above everything and
everyone
else
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart and soul and mind of
strength and so the scribe wanted to
know what is the first the chief the
preeminent commandment that stands above
all others ellen white envisioned
was taken to heaven
and she saw the ark jesus opened it and
she saw the ten commandments
each of them
had a light
but the fourth
had a halo around it
which none of the others had
what's the conclusion
of the ten commandments
the first
and the chief
is commandment four
jesus had twelve
named disciples that traveled with him
he had many more than the twelve but the
twelve that traveled with him
of those twelve
he was closer to three of them
than he was
tonight are you with me
god is the god of degrees
he was closer to peter
james and john
than he was to the other night
jesus frequented the homes of people
he had dinner in the house of simon the
leper
there was a feast in the house of
matthew
there was he spent time in capernaum in
the house of peter where he healed the
mother-in-law of peter
he spent time in the home of mary martha
and lazarus
of all the homes that jesus visited
his favorite
was the home
lazarus he preferred to be there more
than in any other home
and so we read in desire of 88 page 524
paradigm
bless all who sought his help
he loves the whole human family
but to some
he is bound by peculiarly tender
associations
his heart was lit by a strong bond of
affection to the family at bethany
and for one of them
his most wonderful work was wrought she
is saying jesus deliberately reserved
his most mighty miracle for the family
closest to him
[Music]
when god
through moses brought the israelites out
of egypt
here's what god told moses to tell the
israelites
you've seen what i did unto the
egyptians
and how i bear you on eagle's wings and
brought you unto myself
now therefore
if he will obey my voice indeed
then keep my covenant
then you shall be a peculiar treasure
unto me above all people
god is closer to some
than he is to others
deuteronomy 28 verse 1
and it shall come to pass if thou shalt
hearken diligently unto the voice of the
lord thy god
i will observe to do all his
commandments which i command thee this
day
that the lord thy god shall set me on
high
above all nations of the earth
i am simply trying to stress
that god is a god of degrees
this functions in heaven as well
the highest angel gabriel
has more power than any other angel
are you with me
now we apply the principle of degrees to
god's law
love for god
must take preeminence over love for our
fellow man
even though love for god is expressed
through our love for our fellow man but
love for god must be preeminent now
jesus told the scribe thou shalt love
the lord thy god
i with all thy strength now
this
is the first of the two tables
on that table
there were four commandments
thou shalt have know the gods before me
don't worship or make idols
don't take god's name in vain
and remember the sabbath
of the
four the one that identifies who god is
what his office in the universe is
and the territory of his sovereignty
the commander that does that
is command
this is the commandment that is
that identifies god as
creator
now god's
creatorship if there's such a word
is the foundation
of his ownership
let me pause and pray again dear god
please clarify my language
help me to make it so simple the
children will understand
and suppress self
in jesus name
amen
listen to this quotation
education page 137 paragraph four
what did i say
education
page 15
what did i say
that which lies at the foundation
of business integrity
and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership
[Music]
if you're running a business you have a
business
you ought to understand first and
foremost
everything you have belongs to god
that's where elohim counsels us
that which lies at the foundation
of business integrity
and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership
the creator of all things he is the
original proprietor
because he created
everything created belongs to god
colossians 1 16
for by him were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth
visible and invisible whether they be
thrones or dominions or principalities
both things were created by him and for
him and he is before all things and by
him all things consist now when someone
reads a passage of this kind
the tendency is to read it casually and
just move on and not pause to grasp the
seriousness and the literalness of the
passage
[Music]
it is not found in revelation
which is wholly symbolic
christ made
everything
visible
invisible
in heaven
and in earth
this means
your mind
belongs to god
legally
and i've thrown in the word
your senses
belong to god
legally
your health
belongs to god
by right
everything we have
rightfully belongs to god except our
sins
those rightfully belong to us
are you with me now
the ideal human being is an example for
us and who's that
jesus christ
as we continue with holy for god
let's look at how
jesus conducted his life
in harmony with this concept
of holy for god
lord john 7 quickly
you read 14
to 16.
14-16
it is precisely 12 o'clock
[Music]
and i refer to the time from time to
time just to let you know
i am sensitive to time
under the fact you may have other things
to do
do you have john 7
what verses that i say
14-16
now about the midst of the feast jesus
went up into the temple and taught
and the jews marveled saying how north
this man letters having never learned
jesus answered them
read with me now my doctrine
is not mine come on but his that sent me
what i teach is christ is not mine
so when jesus taught the sabbath
he was teaching what somebody taught him
and who was that someone
the father
let me say it again you heard the words
you miss the import of the word
any doctrine jesus christ taught
he taught something that he received
from another source let me add something
else in his humanity
he got that doctrine from someone else
let's
strengthen this point by going to
chapter eight
we read from verse 26
[Music]
our subject holy for god
i have many things to say unto judge of
you
but he that sent me is what true and i
speak to the world what those things
which i have heard of him this is
confirmation of what we read in verse 16
john 7.
they understood not that he spoke to
them of the father
then said jesus unto them
when you have lifted up the son of man
then shall he know that i am he and that
i do nothing of myself
that is not symbolic
when jesus raised lazarus
it was the father who told him to raise
him
when jesus told peter come walk in the
water to me it was the father who told
him tell him come
now this is strange to your mind and to
mine because we don't allow anyone to
tell us anything
mind resists instruction
unless it is instruction for sin
don't tell me anything
don't advise me
i am 16 don't tell me what to look for
in a boyfriend
i know everything i get cancelled from
my other 16 year old friends
[Music]
then said he unto them when you have
lifted up the son of man then shall ye
know that i am he and that i do nothing
of myself but the father which sent me
he taught me what i should say what i
should speak it is the father that told
jesus
what to speak the father taught him
let's go to stage on 8.
let's go to verse 37
our subject
holy for god
our theme
only for christ
i know that you abraham see
but you seek to kill me
because my word hath no place in you let
me pause
and digress hopefully meaningfully
when god's word does not have a
permanent place in your life
and you live longer
[Music]
jesus tells us in john 16
they're doing all these things to me
because they don't know you
let me say it again
church membership is no guarantee of a
christian life
church members said crucify him
i know that you're abraham's seed said
christ
but you seek to kill me
because my word
hath no place in you
it has a place on your shelf
it has a place in your pocketbook
it has no place in your heart
when the restraining word of god
is not in the life
let me say it again that person under
the right provocation
i continue
i know that you're abraham's seed but
you seek to kill me because my word hath
no place in you now listen carefully i
speak that which i have won
seen with my father and ye do that that
you have said with your father jesus
says all that i do
i am patterning or i am following my
father's instructions
it is obvious then if you look at john 7
14-16 john 8 26-28 and 37 uh and other
forces which we can invoke
jesus lived
entirely come on for the father
his life's
theme was holy
in john 6 38
6 minutes after 12.
do you have john 6
verse 38
let me pray again holy father
please god tighten your grip on my mind
my mouth
whatever i require to express this
message you control it for your glory
and our blessing
in jesus name i pray amen
john 6 38 for i came down from heaven
what
not to do
my own will
but the will of him
that's something
[Music]
this is
every other so-called child of god
should follow
[Music]
i have to keep saying that these words
are not symbolic because i don't think
if that has registered in your minds yet
let me say differently by giving you
this
one of the most beautiful quotations you
can read in any book whether written by
ella white or socrates or whomever
the desire of age is page 20 paragraph
two
there is nothing save the selfish heart
of man
that lives unto itself
no bird that claims the air
no animal that moves upon the ground
but ministers to some other life
there is no leaf of the forest
or lowly blade of grass but has its
ministry
every tree and shrub belief
pours forth that element of life
without which neither man nor animal
could live
a man an animal in turn
minister to the life of tree and shrug
the leaf
the flowers breathe fragrance and unfold
the beauty and blessing to the world
the sun sheds its light to gladden a
thousand worlds
the ocean
itself the source of all our springs and
fountains receives the streams from
every land
but takes to give
the mists ascending from its bosom
falling showers to water the earth
that it may bring forth
and bud
what is the condensed meaning of that
quotation
everything created
was created to serve something else
now when you read where she says
every blade of grass
has its ministry
when you leave you'll see grass
pause and look at one blade of grass
and let your mind be challenged
these concepts are foreign to us because
our minds are tainted
but that thing is to be gradually
removed by consistent exposure to the
divine radiation of god's word
take this now and apply to human beings
you and i were not created for our sakes
we were created
for the glory of god
in other words you have nothing to do
with you
one person understood what i just said
let me say it again
you
have nothing to do
with you
i
have nothing to do with me i am on this
earth someone read my mind and finish my
thought
for god
at the risk of being tedious
this is not symbolic
we must live lives
holy
for god
as g or for christ as jesus lived his
life
holy for god
understand this the interaction between
christ and god
is the model for the interaction between
us and christ
you missed it
my fault
let me say differently
the way christ interacted with the
father
is precisely the way
they
must interact with christ
in the light of this message
as verily as christ lived his life holy
for god
finish my thoughts
we must live our lives
holy to christ
which is our theme
[Music]
genesis 1 26
don't go there
say
and god said
let us make man
in our image
before sin
there was one image
when adam sinned a second one popped up
if adam hadn't sinned
all his children
would have been born
in god's image
because adam had no image of his own
a friend of mine asked me many years ago
he said randy
when do i express myself
and i responded with one word hopefully
i was clear never
this is one of the problems in the
church when it comes to fashion
i want to express
myself
[Music]
that's why i wear what i wear
i'll fix my hair do i fix it
or buy the shoes i buy
i want to say to the world
sartorially
this is me
which is also an expensive way to rebel
are you following me
it's a form of rebellion because sin is
rebellion
you are not in this earth
to express yourself
you and i are on this earth finish my
words to express god
this is not my
conclusion this is the bible
corinthians 10 31 say it with me whether
therefore
you eat
or drink
or
whatsoever you do now you tell me
what is excluded from whatsoever
nothing
finish the verse now
do all
you have much
how much
finish it now to the glory of god
listen to me
this is not symbolic
first spirit chapter 1
verse 15
go there with me
let's see how it supports first
corinthians 10 31.
[Music]
towards the back of the bible you should
bump into first peter
do you have it now
14 after 12 find it find it please
that's the problem with screens you see
we no longer know how to find the books
in the bible
and phones you see this
all right
she finally found it
first peter 1 15 what does it say but as
he which have called you come on is holy
finish the verse
holy carefully now reading
microscopically finish the verse in all
manner of confiscation
what's our theme
[Music]
what's our subject
this is the first peter 15 again but as
he which have called you
is holy
when is god not holy on tuesday
it's not only holy on sabbath
[Music]
the bible says as he
which have called you
is holy
so be holy
in all
manner of conversation
go to first timothy chapter four
victory verse eight
first timothy four listen to the apostle
paul writing to a young man and of
course a young lady will benefit just as
much because truth applies to everyone
first timothy chapter 4 reading verse 8.
[Music]
we have it now
for bodily exercise come on profited
but godliness come on is profitable come
on to all three
when you buy clothes
be driven by godliness
when you at the right age
set your eyes on a young lady
be driven
by godliness
not her hips and lips
when you consider an academic degree
that will cost your parents so much
money
be driven finish my words by god
when you go to
wherever restaurants you go
you have the menu
and it's your whole list of dead animals
finish my words
be driven
my god
for bodily exercise prophetess little
but godliness is profitable unto all
things now finish the verse
microscopically having promised come on
of the life that now is
end of the life to come
godliness extends beyond this life
when this is the way you live your life
[Music]
then you and i will match our theme
holy
for christ
as christ was
holy
for god
whether therefore he eat
[Music]
or drink
all whatsoever
he do
[Music]
we do not believe that kind of approach
build that approach
and narrow
and oppose our freedom
because our natural condition is to see
the benefits of sin
and to view the horrors of holiness
and so when the devil spoke to eve
he said he shall not surely die
[Music]
give me one word for that
disobedience
give me a smaller version of
then your eyes
shall be opened benefit one
it had no foundation true
and you shall be as gods benefit too no
foundation
knowing good and evil
[Music]
the devil presented sin
as attractive
he never used the word sin
or disobedience
and he did his work of marketing so well
that eve bought the product
see a good thing at the store we go tell
our friends
so she met her husband
and he went along
my brothers and sisters
if they had followed the principle of
for god
holy for god
they would never have eaten of that
fruit
many of you are in college how many of
you in college makes your hands a
university some form of all right
let me
guess
[Music]
what are you
yes
medicine
i'm tempted to ask you to tell me one of
the 12 cranial nerves but i will not do
that
[Music]
are you studying medicine tell me loudly
you want to help people and you said it
because you guessed that's what i wanted
to hear
anyone else who raised the hair
i'm quite serious anyone else raise
their hand oh yes what are you studying
physics physics
now
under the force of honesty
and in the presence of a holy god
surrounded by witnesses
why did you choose physics
okay initially i was doing geology
okay but it had nothing to do with god
no but you're a christian
and that's a problem
here's a christian who does things have
no connections with god
you see when some
the choice of a degree
must be driven
by godliness
in other words how will this advance the
glory of god
let me tell you something
listen carefully
this is why we're not blessed
[Music]
do not belong to god
so he doesn't listen
you're not
[Music]
now god is so good there are general
blessings that god bestows matthew 5 45
he makes his son to rise on the evil and
of the good and send them reign on the
just and on the unjust those are general
blessings but the
specific
choices blessings
the ones that cause the angels to marvel
they are reserved
for those who live
holy for christ
let me tell you something god blesses
what's his
when your life is not his
yes god will sprinkle some blessings on
you just to preserve you so you come to
the place where you accept him then he
can send a tsunami
there are christians blaming god god is
not nice to me he has given me nothing
your life does not belong to god
he has no legal basis
to pour out the fullness of his blessing
testimonies volume 5 is 341 paragraph 1
fallen man is satan's lawful captive
there is a degree of legality
not legalism
legality because we have a law
fallen man
is satan's lawful capital
the sinner rightfully and legally
belongs to satan
i didn't say the person who occasionally
makes a mistake no
i said the sinner whose lifestyle that's
the lifestyle that person lawfully
belongs to the devil
and god does not pour out blessings in
heaven
[Music]
but he wants to bless your lives
so he tells you
come to me
leave where you are
and come
well let me change my words call me and
i will break you out from where you are
because you can't leave
are you falling
holy
for christ
so that when you see jesus said to
philip john 14 and i'm coming to the
close
philip said in john 14 verse 8 lord
show us the father
and it sufficeth us before i go any
further let me pray again god in heaven
let me not drift into self-expression
but god i offer myself as your servant
your slave
you tell me what to say i'll say it
in jesus name amen
philip said unto him lord
show us the father
and it suffices us
jesus said unto him have i been so long
time with you and yet hast thou not
known me phil
ye that have seen me you finish it
you have seen the father now this is
jesus and the father
that's holy
for the father
you and i must come to the place
where it can be saved
he that have seen them finish my words
have seen jesus
this is not symbolic
if you look at christ
you look at the believer you're not sure
who's new
because they are alike
the humanity of christ is our example
and christ listen to how christ lives
such a powerful life desire video space
664 paragraph four
what did i say
how many of you wrote it down
ah god bless you sister you want us
christ revealed no qualities
and exercised no powers
that men may not have
through
faith his perfect humanity
is that which all his followers may
possess
what is she saying we can live the life
that jesus christ lived
not in our strength because christ did
not live in history
listen to how the quotation ends his
perfect humanity is that which all
his followers may possess
if they will be in subject
you know why christ has not yet come
it is not because
we need more advertised colleges to
become universities
that's not why he has to come
it is not because we need to build more
hospitals that's not why he doesn't
or people need to have more children
we are not yet
living
holy for christ
christ is waiting with longing desire
for the manifestation of himself
in his people
when the character of christ shall be
in his church his people
say he will come to claim to us is all
so the delay of christ is because the
church is not holy for christ
and then we blame the papacy
you know god is not waiting for the
papacy to do anything
he's waiting for us
we blame the illuminati
we blame the muslims
they're hard to win
we blame the hindus
we blame the buddhists
they're hard to win
the hardest people god had to deal with
with israelites
[Music]
you couldn't win them
are you listening to me
my brothers and sisters
children of god
make
a decision
because if your life is not you see
the only way god can save you well let
me say differently
holy for god holy for christ
if you surrender to christ 99
you're lost
you see the devil only needs one percent
to destroy your life
[Music]
all of me
in order to save me
so his desire for holy for god and holy
for christ is not based on
self-centeredness it is based on our the
only way god can save you is if you're
holy heals
i'll express it differently
matthew 10 37 he that loveth father and
mother more than me is not worthy of me
christ is saying i must be first you see
god can only save us if he occupies
posse
they shall
cannot save you from position too
you're not listening
[Music]
i have to say it again
it is only when god is first in my life
it is only from that vantage position
that he can save me
any other position
and the advantage goes to the enemy
and so this thing holy or holy for
christ
is very very serious
and when i deal with end time events
this afternoon
i will come at it in a very very
different way
i have nothing to say about the paper
the little time of jacob's trouble
the big time of jacob's trouble
the sunday law
the close of probation
the falling of the seven last plague i
have nothing to do with that
but i will discuss end times
i have a question for you don't answer
me
[Music]
have you given your life
entirely to christ
answers no
do it
before you leave
do it before you get up out of your
chair
because death does not send a text
neither god nor the devil sends a text
to tell you this is your last moment on
earth
are you with me
do not leave this building
without
giving your life
entirely to christ to god having heard
what you've heard do not
leave this building
with the arrogance that i will still
continue to live do i live because i'll
be alive five years from now i will just
before the close of probation i will
give my life to christ
do it before you leave
because the most blessed life
is the life that is placed
in the hands of god
because those in his hands cannot be
plucked out
yes
fine jesus
came face to face with the demoniac of
the gatherings
and the description of the man is such
that neither could any man tame him or
bind him because that he had been often
bound with fetters and chains and the
chains had been plucked asundered by him
and defectors broken in pieces might
look at any man tame him
and always day and night he was in the
mountains and in the tombs crying and
cutting himself with stone people saw
him unravel
[Music]
no one could restrain him
that's the devil
but when he saw jesus afar off
he ran and worshipped him
and cried with loud voices said gee what
if i to thee jesus thou shalt the most
high god are you journey by god that
thou told may do not
for he had said unto him come out of the
man the unclean spirit
and jesus asked him what is my name
and he answered saying my name is legion
for we are many now listen to verse 10.
this is the demon now
and he besought him much
that he would not send them away out of
the country
the demons begged jesus
don't send this away
[Music]
verse 11
now there was there nigh unto the
mountains a great herd of slide feeding
and all the devils besought him to
beseech his debate send us into the
swine that we may enter into them
unfortunately jesus gave them leave and
their unclean spirits entered into the
swine of the herd ran firing down the
stupidest into the sea what i'm trying
to tell you that two thousand demons up
against one man named that one man jesus
christ and they all begged him
when your life is in the hands of god
satan has to beg god can you say it
and so jesus said to peter simon simon
satan have desired to see have you that
he may seek to his weak but i have
prayed for thee
the devil went to jesus for permission
but if simon peter had not been a
child of god satan needs no permission
to harass his own people
[Music]
am i talking to
myself let me close the book as a visual
symbol
i am about to end
when your life belongs to god
the devil needs
permission
[Music]
when your life
don't apply
for god's sweetest blessings
when your life belongs to god
the devil will complain to god as he
complained about job has not thou made a
hedge about him
and about his house
and about all that he have on every side
some people the businesses keep failing
because they don't belong to god
and so they try and it fails they try
and it fails they try and it fails why
because the glory of god was not the
motivation behind their business
and some go to school no tuition no
tuition why because the chance of a
degree had nothing to do with the glory
of god
the universe
are under the control of christ
for your blessing
that's not my view that's the bible
according to the working of his mighty
power which he wrought in christ when he
raised him from the dead and set him at
his own right hand in the heavenly
places far above all principalities and
powers and might and dominions and every
name that is named not only this world
but also that which is to come and hath
put all things under his feet
and gave him to be the head over all
things to the church let me say it again
all the treasures of heaven
are in the command of christ
for the blessing
but we must live our lives three words
tell me
holy
for christ
give christ your education
give him your bank account
give him your romantic life
give him your family life
give him your recreational life
give him your house
and not jump give him your car
let me tell you what happened to me that
i'll close many many years ago
i had a little honda crx they don't make
them anymore
a little carvey kid loved it
and i used to drive very fast
the lord killed me of that
painlessly
and
one day i was in the parking lot about
to go somewhere and i said father
this car is yours
you gave me the money to buy it
i'll drive it on your fifa
i'll put in the gas change the old
italian but it is yours and i
acknowledge this car
as yours
what i'm about to tell you is fact
two weeks later they checked the mileage
just out of cuba not
connected to what i said to god you know
just checking how my car is performing i
was getting 10 more miles per gallon
than i was before because i checked it
i used to get 36 miles together
when i dedicated the car to god
and it had nothing to do with my use
my mileage went to 46 miles per hour
[Music]
many of us are sick because our bodies
do not belong to god
mind character and personality volume 1
page 34 paragraph 3. i want to ask you
what i said
hello i write
let the mind become intelligent
and the will be placed on the lord's
side
and there will be a wonderful
improvement in the physical health
without doing anything else a surrender
of the life to god holy completely and
without reservation creates immediately
an improvement in the health
you're not visiting the pharmacist or
the chemist whatever you call them
i know i'm repetitious but i'm compelled
to be give your life to god without
reservation
you ask how do i do that you just do it
you say lord
here is my life
let me say it again
if your life does not belong to god
it is not god's fault that he cannot
bless the way he wants to
give your love to god
and for those who do not know how to say
lord i give you my life then say god
father i don't know how to give it i ask
you
but take it and be the god of my life
how many of you will say father and say
it seriously god doesn't joke they're
not jokes in the bible
father
to the best of my ability i give you my
life
my education
my health
my dress choices
my eating choices
my romantic choices
i commit all of that to you to the best
of my ability if you say that there's
your right hand
don't look around just keep looking
straight at me
stand up
quietly quiet
here's my high school
father
if i preach badly forgive me
if i was a little too hard on your
children
and you do not take it lightly when they
treat it harshly
my intention their father was to impress
upon them the importance of living holy
for christ
of a god
that we will live only for jesus as he
lived only for you
no variation they got precisely the same
way
where i fell short let the spirit make
up the difference father
now god
in the name of jesus christ
who came in our fallen nature
and demonstrated how to live only for
god
in his name
by the power of his life
accept those who make commitments right
in your presence
to give the life completely to you
father help them to understand this
commitment must be renewed
every day
i pray father even now as they stand
that you will grant them a measure of
your spirit
that will sustain them in this decision
which the devil doesn't like but all of
heaven is rejoicing
please god
help them to understand in the youth
in the figure of youth their god
that the sooner the life is given
completely to you
this is the more likely it is to live a
life free of regrets
because so many regrets are rooted in
youthful decisions
please god
trouble that young man who's hesitating
trouble that young lady who's so
fascinated by the world she realizes to
commit her life to you will have her
separating from the world and she is
caught between heaven and hell
our father by this
power of the spirit just ludge her over
the line
on the side of heaven
she'll be glad you did
please father
give us a hatred for the world
and a love for the things of heaven
your servant writes
in the review in herald january 24 1880
if your thoughts
your plans
your purposes
are all directed toward the accumulation
of the things of earth
your anxiety your study your interests
will all be centered upon the world the
heavenly attractions will lose their
beauty
the glories of the eternal world will
cease to have the force of reality to
you
and this is the condition many of us are
reigning because our minds are on the
earth not in heaven
i ask you one more time holy father in
humility
acknowledge help us to understand the
importance
it has important that it stretches to
eternity the importance of living holy
for christ
this is why you were given life
and your servant writes in historical
sketches page 285 paragraph four every
youth should be impressed with the fact
that he's not his own
that his strength his time his talents
belong to god
it should be his chief purpose in life
to glorify god and to do good to his
fellow man
please father
reach these young people particularly
because all things being able to have a
long life ahead of them if christ still
delays
let them find their greatest joy
in reflecting you
and let their lives lead others to jesus
please hear me
not just the young bless everyone under
the sound of my voice
ease our burdens day god
wipe away our tears
and bless us i pray
in jesus name and for his sake let god's
people say amen
you